hello again you're watching the press
preview first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive tonight time
to see what's making the headlines with
the daily mails consultant editor andrew
pearce and the daily mirrors associate
editor kevin mcguire they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages the guardian leads with the
ukrainian president's plea to western
leaders to help stop his country being
quote erased by russian forces picturing
a tearful woman taking cover in a kiev
metro station with many other people the
financial times has the headline
russians batter ukrainian cities
putin lays waste to city says the times
which focuses on the bombardment of
civilians in mariopol and kharkiv the
telegraph leads with the reported
surrender of the strategically
significant city of herson
using an image of a mother cradling a
baby in an air aid shelter the eye
declares welcome to hell
another infant is on the front of the
mirror which pleads for his sake for his
future stop
meanwhile the express leads with
discontent in russia's ranks after the
country announced 498 of its troops had
now died
the metro describes the ukrainian
people's resilience a week after the
invasion as their finest hour
the start dubs protesters who blocked a
road to a nuclear reactor heroes
the mail says the duchess of cornwall
will give a substantial donation to the
papers fund for ukrainian refugees
and the sun splashes on that news that
chelsea owner and the russian oligarch
roman ibramovic has announced that he
will sell the club
just a quick reminder scan the qr code
that you see on your screen during the
program and you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
right we're joined today by
andrew and kevin
lovely to see you both if only it was in
happier times let's start with the
telegraph shall we kevin
first city falls to russia
quite a significant moment this isn't it
yeah i'm afraid it was inevitable it was
going to happen sometime and it seems to
be herson where the electricity water
had been cut cut off there were no
trains out
the mayor wanted to end the slaughter
didn't want russian troops shooting
civilians so they've surrendered and
according to the telegraph certain
conditions of being imposed people only
allowed to go out in ones and twos not
large crowds curfews and
you know ukraine uh
the heroism uh and defiance of the
defenders has been rightly praised but
they're just heavily outgunned by the
russian uh military machine that's been
assembled by putin may not have gone as
well as
putin had hoped early on but the
onslaught is there anything we can see
from the tv pictures and reports coming
out of ukraine all the still pictures in
in newspapers
that the armor is coming forward now
more missiles are being fired the
shelling of cities and it is absolutely
horrific because we're watching this
unfold in part of europe three hours
flight away
um from uh from the uk it's it's on our
doorstep it's on our continent
unfortunately we've been
used or too often
seen these terrible scenes in the middle
east and parts of asia parts of africa
but here it is now
happening uh
in our neighborhood in our time and it
is absolutely heartbreaking
it really really is and reports coming
out of kalasam we're not too sure what's
going on there but
andrew this it does feel like today
there was a definite
change in how the russians
are
attacking basically didn't it
yeah they're going back to classic siege
uh tactics now the the the great uh 40
mile
of tanks and armored cars is still
making incredibly slow progress thank
god to uh the russia to the ukraine
capital so
putin is relying on it's almost the
cowardly way to fight he's bombarding
civilian targets schools hospitals
orphanages nothing sacred a university
flattened uh with
the heavy firepower he's got which the
ukrainians can't respond to
uh he succeeded in in capturing one city
others will fall too
uh but he's gonna have a hell of a fight
in his hands if he thinks he's gonna get
into
the capital and other cities will also
resist too it is an extraordinary uh
experience watching this uh the heroism
the bravery seeing those men putting
their families their children on the
trains and their wives they have to stay
anywhere between 18 and 60 to fight and
they want to fight because they want to
defend their country and they want to
repel these russian invaders some of
whom we've seen are deeply reluctant
we've seen footage of haven't we on sky
today of young russians conscripts
captured bursting into tears some of
them didn't even know they were going to
be fighting in ukraine they presumably
thought they were on an extended
training exercise then they discover
that being expected to kill people who
they frankly regard as kiss and king it
would be a bit like
wales being
welsh people being told they've got to
start shooting english people and
scottish people and english people vice
versa it's really really uh
a great tragedy unfolding as kevin says
right on our doorstep who would have
thought it in europe one of our most
beautiful european countries and um
being bombarded
it reminds me of what he did in chechnya
back in 1999 2000 the siege of grosney 8
000 civilians were killed by putin he
doesn't care
yeah it really does it's so
heartbreaking and it just seems so
pointless doesn't it let's have a look
at the front of the guardian their
headline that russia wants to erase us
warns ukraine's president
also in the last hour or so the icc
saying that they're immediately going to
an investor open up an investigation
into possible war crimes we saw the pm
today saying he thinks there already
have been war crimes committed yeah
i mean kevin
russia wants to erase us
it does seem that that's what they want
to do
yeah i think i think he's right i'm not
sure it's genocide in the sense of
killing everybody of a political
religious uh but using cluster
ammunitions things like that yeah but it
but it certainly is uh
ukraine ceasing to exist uh putin wanted
to be part of a wider russian empire
and at most being a vassal state with a
puppet quizling
leader and cow towing to him so zelensky
who of course is there their target
number one and you should think what
will happen what will happen should the
russians either capture or kill him i
hope there are
procedures and i'm sure there are in
ukraine on who takes over and who
attempts to rally the the opposition
should that uh should that happen but if
he's right they want to remove
ukraine as it exists now as a as a
sovereign sovereign state he doesn't he
doesn't want that so you understand
those appeals and that's so powerful
that he that he makes and
he was kind of because he was a comedian
he was an actor you know playing playing
the uh playing somebody who became
president uh he got elected
back by oligarchs uh to to do it and it
was a
checkered history should we say in the
years since he was elected but he's
risen to this uh occasion incredibly
well but the guardians are also
focusing two on the humanitarian crisis
of unfolding in
ukraine with a health world health
organization just warning food is
running out there's problems with
medical treatment people will will cease
to have access to water there will be no
power because the russians will target
the
civilian infrastructure in order to
terrorize the population into
into submission or attempted submission
and
some local leaders have to make very
difficult decisions on whether they
continue resisting or to save lives they
effectively surrender and that's what
we're hearing out of maripol the mayor
there saying that we we have no water
and that is what they're doing targeting
the infrastructure andrew you you
touched on their their fighting spirit
and so much
has been made about how they have
rallied and zielinski and how miserable
he seems but at the end of the day you
can have all the fighting spirit you
want if you're up against vladimir
putin's war machine inevitably you will
fall
yeah look they can't hang on forever
they haven't got enough food they
haven't got water uh he is cynically
targeting the civilian infrastructure
power uh nuclear power electricity uh
he's going he know he knows how to do
this because he's done it before
but the but the resistance will continue
long after some of the major cities fall
because so many people have been armed
uh the arms are still coming in from
across across the world even sweden
which has never got involved in arming
countries before is sending arms to
ukraine germany we know he's doing the
same so it's a pretty well armed a
pretty well-armed uh civilian militia in
a sense but of course they've got
nothing to match the firepower of the
putin missiles
but uh when he if and when he does
conquer ukraine i think he's going to be
in for a long uncomfortable occupation
much like afghanistan and we know how
that ended in the end the russian bear
left with its tail between its legs
because he could never ever uh suppress
the mujahideen and they thought and
fought and they had the spirit of lions
and that's what we're seeing in um
ukraine again
kevin let's have a look at the the
mirrors front page the striking image
just talk us through that
yeah i'd also point out just uh after
andrew of course nato up to 20 years of
the us uk
also to leave afghanistan you could you
can topple governments but it's very
hard to occupy and pacify and control
the country if it doesn't want to be it
doesn't want to be controlled but uh but
the uh
it's it's all about people of course
it's about people this is what it is and
uh the mirror has got a picture of a
father with a very very young baby in uh
in a bombshell the eye have done
something similar they have a mother
holding on and this is just awful
particularly when you've got young young
kids or you're giving birth to birth the
babies should be really happy joyous
occasion you should be taking great you
know
emotional and support from the child
giving it to the child and these parents
must be worried witness
about their children whether they're
going to survive what's going to going
to happen and it it just it it
it breaks your heart
when you you see it i'm not sure if
putin's really got any emotional
uh
strands left and he is uh
in his heart is that 20 odd years have
absolutely hardened him into somebody
who is only concerned about putin and
his uh
his crackpot uh ideas and his ideology
and his his intention to
rebuild a russian a russian empire but
though those pictures of those kids and
you know i mean they are you just you
just now worry what will happen at them
to happen because they're caught they're
caught in a water
and they're in areas that have been
shelled
and of course shelling is just it's
indiscriminate to a large large degree
you can't in an urban area you're using
cluster munitions
just briefly um
andrew we've got 30 seconds what do you
think of abramovic saying he's going to
sell chelsea it's on the front of the
sun
well i don't know why they ever let him
buy the flipping club in the first place
blair was blair was in number 10 at the
time um i think it's great he's going
he's doing it to protect his back he
wants to get out he's worried about his
money he's not going to make chelsea pay
the million at a billion and a half eos
but it would have been quite nice if if
uh
will go to help ukraine but he hasn't
condemned putin